lawmakers faced tough questions over it
an explosive 60 minutes report it found
Congress helped disarm the Drug
Enforcement Administration during the
height of the opioid crisis the
investigation with the Washington Post
highlights the impact of a new law
sponsored by Republicans and approved by
Democrats drug overdose deaths in this
country have more than doubled over the
past decade take a look at this map
about what it looked like in 1999 and
here's how it looked in 2015 just 16
years later the CDC says more than
33,000 Americans died from
opioid-related overdoses in 2015 alone
Joe Rannazzisi used to run the DEA
office of diversion control which
regulates the pharmaceutical industry he
told Bill Whitaker on 60 minutes that
the opioid crisis was aided in part by
Congress lobbyists and the drug
distribution industry if I was gonna
write a book about how to harm the
United States with pharmaceuticals the
only thing I can think of that would
immediately harm is to take the
authority away from the the the
investigative agency that is trying to
enforce the Controlled Substances Act in
this and the regulations implemented
under the Act and that's what this bill
did the bill introduced in the house by
Pennsylvania Congressman Tom Marino and
congresswoman Marsha Blackburn of
Tennessee was promoted as a way to
ensure that patients had access to the
pain medication they needed Johnathan
Novak who worked in the DDA's legal
office says what the bill really did was
strip the agency of its ability to
immediately freeze suspicious shipments
of prescription narcotics to keep drugs
off US streets what the DEA calls
diversion you're not gonna be able to
hold anyone higher up the food chain
accountable because of this law because
of this law how hard does it make your
job and going after the wholesale
distributors I I would say it makes it
nearly impossible this 2015 Justice
Department memo we obtained supports
that it states the bill could actually
result in increased diversion abuse
and Public Health and Safety
consequences they're toothless I don't I
don't know how they stop this now it's a
very sad state of affairs